all right so it has come to my attention
that people feel that I only review
older movies if I like the movie so I
figured hey why not review this movie
here we go
[Music]
Super Mario Brothers the movie you gotta
admit what just popped up in your
subscription box you were like why is
that happening
so the Super Mario Brothers movie is
based off of the Super Mario Brothers
game kind of not really at all it stars
Bob Hoskins it's a pretty legit looking
Mario John Leguizamo is Luigi somehow
and they all go into another world is it
the Mushroom Kingdom from Super Mario
Brothers no not really although it's
referenced as the Mushroom Kingdom once
it's a place called Dino Hatton because
what happened in the Super Mario
Brothers movie is 65 million years ago a
meteor hits the earth and dinosaurs get
wiped out only they don't get wiped out
the meteors like fragmented reality and
so the dinosaurs all lived in a parallel
dimension where they evolved into
intelligent beings like us and they even
evolved into mammals somehow because
they have hair like full heads of hair
they look exactly like us it makes
little to no sense in fact it makes no
sense
yeah because you know instead of having
something really out there like a couple
of plumbers go through a pipe and end up
in the Mushroom Kingdom
they have to do something a little more
realistic and relatable like a meteor
splitting the world into two halves and
dinosaurs evolving into intelligent
human beings we got Dennis Hopper
playing King Koopa he's more commonly
known as Bowser but back in the day you
know early 90s and 80s he was called
King Koopa or Bowser both names same guy
yeah you know Dennis hoppers great no
this is not his shining moment I'm
pretty sure this is not what we want to
remember him by I gotta assume someone's
like hey you want to play the bad guy in
a Super Mario movie he was like cool
what do I got to do and they were like
nothing you just gotta wear a suit and
have your head look like an inside-out
open to orange and boom you're the bad
guy in a Mario movies other than the
script being terrible the acting is
absolutely abysmal - I'll give credit to
a couple of people for giving it their
all in the Super Mario Brothers movie
Dennis Hopper and Bob Hoskins really did
the best job humanly possible with this
material everyone else John Leguizamo
nope Samantha Mathis you're lucky you're
cute they could not have made a movie
that was farther from Super Mario
Brothers if they really tried for
instance you have toad toad you know
he's an iconic Mario character let's
make toad a 40 year old band hippy yeah
that makes sense it makes perfect sense
I don't know how pre-production in this
movie
but I gotta assume something happened
like someone wrote a script that was so
bizarre you know dinosaurs and other
dimensions and everything sparks when
you drive it every vehicle just shoots
out Sparks a really shitty looking city
in a desert I'm just saying it was it
was weird so I got to believe the studio
I saw the script and they were like we
no one's gonna watch this piece-of-shit
movie but if we throw in some Super
Mario Brothers elements and then call it
Super Mario Brothers maybe they well
they didn't but I gotta assume that's
how it went down this is really what the
Super Mario Brothers movies like I'm not
even kidding you're gonna think I'm
kidding and trying to get laughs I'm not
it's like Michael Bay smoked a lot of
weed licked a lot of toads and dropped a
lot of acid and among him tripping all
sorts of balls was like hey I want to
make a movie that's like a mix between
Super Mario Brothers and Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome but more Thunderdome
elements than Mario elements it's really
important we got a half Thunderdome
because things got explode useless
explosions cars always hitting each
other shit's always flipping you're just
watching it going oh the studio's gotta
be so pissed that this money is just
gone now he's here the dollar signs
racking up as things exploding you're
like that's that money could have gone
anywhere else in the world like [ __ ]
doesn't make sense I'm gonna spoil this
but this is at the very beginning of the
movie and if you really care about
spoilers from the Super Mario Brothers
movie honestly I'm being honest with you
right here this is real see this real it
doesn't matter
Daisy's mom dies in this cave 20 years
later scientists are like digging up the
bones couple things about that one she
said her snout still looks like a
dinosaur she didn't look like a dinosaur
does she suddenly looked like a dinosaur
when she dies
second of all can the paleontologist not
tell that these bones are from 20 years
ago I got to know this because someone
needs to be fired at that point I
realized it's made for kids because it
has all a little wonky sound effect you
know when something gets hit it's all
dying and aiming for the kid demographic
is absolutely solidified when someone
gets hit from this Devo gun otherwise
known as a painted black super scope
sticks and they devolve into an ape and
everyone's like laughing does the dudes
like you know a dick in the movie like
they're really laughing I'd be like holy
[ __ ] this is monkey now superscope
six-shot the guy he's a monkey give coop
of the world the world you are you
laughing but if you want something
productive to have come from the Super
Mario Brothers movie take heart knowing
that the actors fidgeting with a little
painted up superscope stick so this
probably accounts for 50% of the use of
the super scope 6 ever got in its life
it's like the power glove bazooka right
there you think the people who wrote the
suit
Mario Brothers script step back after it
was done we're like you know what this
is the greatest thing to come out of
Hollywood since the Immortals being from
the planet sliced in Highlander too why
don't they make a Super Mario Brothers
movie how is Super Mario Brothers movies
should be made you know like Disney or
Pixar pick up the rise and just make a
CGI movies CGI animation something that
works for Super Mario Brothers it could
be really solid really good we won't be
stuck with this being the Super Mario
Brothers movie that happened it is not
right to call this Super Mario Brothers
it's nothing like Super Mario Brothers
and in a weird way I think this movie
could be a good time if I was trashed
yeah and now it's a oh there's an
element of me that thinks that if I were
smashed
I would enjoy you know in that way that
you use this movie to torment your
friends my friends were all sitting in a
room we're all having a party or hanging
out or something like that I can just
pop in Mario Brothers movie be like hey
you're all gonna hate this [ __ ] in the
course of my life in my time on YouTube
I've seen a lot of [ __ ] movies I'm like
the Dread Pirate Roberts I've built an
immunity to horrible movies but you guys
you're probably gonna die so what video
game would you like to see be made into
a movie
what is it whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]